so donald trump had another humiliating
24 hours ending yesterday
on the eve of the republican national
convention which starts tonight
first of course trump golfed on saturday
as the coronavirus death toll
reached and surpassed 180 000 deaths
okay we're a global embarrassment
trump is still golfing don't need to
spend a lot of time on that
sunday trump announces a big press
briefing
huge medical announcement is going to be
made big treatment news about
coronavirus
wow what could that be they schedule it
for 5 30.
word leaks the announcement
is an fda emergency use authorization
for convalescent plasma what
that's been around as a coronavirus
trial treatment for months
tons of countries have been using
condolences how is how is that an
announcement that trump
what what that is what it was donald
trump
trying to take credit for something he
had nothing to do with
isn't news and isn't unique to the
united states and of course
donald trump continues to mispronounce
the word plasma
as plasma seven times in fact during
this announcement here is trump
struggling to even read what the
announcement is truly historic
announcement in our battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
the fda has issued an emergency
use authorization and
that's such a a powerful term emergency
use
authorization for a treatment known as
convalescent plasma
why can't somebody tell them it's plasma
is that like when you forget someone's
name
the second time you meet them and you
don't want to ask and then you've met
them 10 times
and now it's too late to ask and at this
point nobody wants to be the person to
go up to trump and say
sir as trump says people talk to him sir
it's plasma not
plasma then more importantly
substantively trump exaggerated the
benefit of plasma or plasma
as it may be vaccine to save lives we're
removing unnecessary barriers and delays
not by cutting corners but by marshaling
the full power of the federal government
we provided 48 million dollars to fund
the mayo clinic study that tested the
efficacy of convalescent plasma for
patients with
the virus through this study over one
hundred thousand americans have already
enrolled
to receive this treatment and it has
proven to reduce mortality by 35 percent
it's a tremendous number the fda mit
harvard and mount sinai hospital have
also found convalescent plasma to be a
very effective
method of fighting this horrible disease
based on the science
and the data the fda has made the
independent determination that the
treatment is safe
and very effective now there are actual
questions about whether this emergency
use authorization
makes sense so to remind you this is a
trial treatment that's been around the
world for months there's nothing special
about the us
trying convalescent plasma there's a
good
uh thread on twitter which explains that
by giving an emergency authorization
you're making the treatment available to
way more people who aren't actually that
sick and who would likely recover
anyway and could end up skewing the
results
and exposing people to some pretty
serious side effects which can include
as a result of these plasma transfusions
lung injury
blood clots kidney issues etc so one of
the reasons you would maybe not do
an eua early is that when you keep the
treatment as part of randomly controlled
trials
you're actually carefully selecting
sicker patients
where you need something extra i have a
relative in argentina
who has coronavirus right now and they
would have been able to give her
convalescent plasma but they decided
she's not sick enough
and because there are side effects it we
don't want to just start giving it to
everybody at this point in time you
don't want to put people who aren't that
sick
at risk of dangerous side effects and
skew the results
by giving the treatment to people who
are less sick and likely to recover
anyway when you have an emergency use
authorization
people start asking for this it's more
available you start giving it to people
who aren't that sick
you end up with people with side effects
that didn't really need the treatment
and the treatment can appear more
effective than it is
all because trump wants something to
announce
okay so then trump takes just three
questions at a completely non-newsworthy
press briefing
one of the questions is from right wing
propaganda network
oan and then he walks off so quickly
after only three questions that you can
tell the other people on the stage
are surprised that that's it trump's
leaving take a look
very much great question was there
pressure on you dr hahn to authorize
this mr dr hahn
could you answer every question
authorize this you didn't answer the
question not gonna answer the question
so that was part one of trump's late
afternoon
then trump was interviewed by this
horrible fox news host steve hilton
and it was just a train wreck yet again
this was another one of those interviews
meant to be easy
that just goes bad for trump trump has
been asked about
and has failed to answer what's your
biggest accomplishment from your first
term
trump in the past has given no answer
multiple times to that question
this time he had an answer and comically
it was worse than no answer at all trump
says his big accomplishments
are health care and transparency listen
to this
with healthcare we've done a great job
one of the other things i did i think
you do
one of the future is good um
transparency
i approve transparency that's bigger
than healthcare
the people i had working on and one of
them is like the all-time
expert on transparency highly respected
ben doctor
he said sir if you get this approved
this is bigger than health care
transparency where you can go and
negotiate and
pick the best explain why that helps
people because people will be able to
negotiate their prices
which right now they can people will be
able to get better doctors
you know it's good for good hospitals by
the way hospitals are against it
because it makes them good good
hospitals and good doctors it's good for
good hospitals it's the biggest thing
maybe in health care of anything i'm
doing
so let's think that through health care
trump
tried twice i believe in 2017
to get a plan passed that would replace
obamacare with something that would
lead to 24 to 32 million people
losing health care then what he did on
health care
is strip the man the mandate from
obamacare which merely makes obamacare
function worse
it doesn't actually get rid of it it
just makes it function worse
then he says transparency has been an
accomplishment
i don't even have to get into that i
mean you know
logan act hatch act violations lining
his pockets and those of his family and
friends
not showing us his taxes not cooperating
with multiple investigations so
his accomplishments he says are
healthcare and transparency
out of this world and then again trump
says
he's been the best president for black
people in history
other than maybe abraham lincoln what do
you have to say to people who want
both law and order and racial justice
first of all i think i've done more
for the black community than any other
president other than perhaps abraham
lincoln and i think it's true with
criminal justice reform and opportunity
zones and all of the things i've done
a prison reform i mean what i've done is
more than anybody else
i don't know if it's being recognized at
all this little clip
those 23 seconds are everything that
trump is
i've done the most of anybody and nobody
gives me credit that is the trump
presidency in a nutshell
failing on everything while claiming
success
and claiming nobody's giving you credit
for that success
another disastrous day for trump by
normal people standards
leading up to the rnc which starts
tonight it's going to be wild
it's going to be wild make sure you're
following me on twitter at deepakman i
will be tweeting during the rnc
and live streaming i hope to see you
then
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com slash pacman
i've been using privacy for a little
over a year now you've heard me talk
about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy the virtual card number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use
a virtual credit card number you're
keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank
or credit card info protected against
data breaches
and identity theft and it's free there's
no catch whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a ten dollar a month
plan that gives you one percent cash
back and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman